hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign so we're
gonna be talking about some of the
changes in the patch from last week new
rank changes and the roadmap coming to
August so as always look to be if you do
enjoy discover if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being belts changes here Oh updates
leaks events stuff all the type of good
things so a new patch was released I
believe last week in a few details you
may have noticed like half health when
you revive somebody the valcon reward
and reworks obviously in the new maps
the Kuti keep as well as the new
tournament ranks master and grant master
ranks which you've no doubt seen a lot
of people talk about the bear trap the
fire trap and the stun trap of all had
increased cooldowns as well and the Fiat
Lux now to zero damage instead of 25
like I said this is from last week's you
no doubt already know about this but I
thought I'd included anyway most of the
rest were just bug fixes so I'll leave
the link in the description down below
if you want to check every single detail
in the patch and like I've stated in my
streams multiple times but I haven't
officially said it some of the weapons I
showed in my previous video were
actually season 8 gear and not season 7
the developers accidentally showed the
wrong weapon so that is possibly the
reason why you haven't gotten the weapon
you want yet just to let everybody knows
a quick PSA there's also changes coming
to ranked 1 huge changes leaving a
ranked game will not decrease skill
rating so they're going to be getting
rid of the exploit some of you
especially in the Grand Master ranks may
have already seen this by now the issue
with this is that accounts for a
disconnection as well so if you
accidentally got disconnected you will
now lose skill rating it sucks but it's
better than having this exploit running
around ruining ranked and if you do
leave that you will receive a 40%
deduction on your skill rating or rank
and you will have a 30 minute penalty
meaning you cannot play range for 30
whole minutes and also the people who
use the exploit the most will have their
entire rank reset having to do all 15 of
their placement matches again when they
come back onto ranked again ranked
orders are also coming to the game as
well in the near future and rank duel
tournament will also be coming this
weekend as well which is pretty nice the
original plan was to have dual
tournament replace dual ranked on the
weekends but now they're going to change
it just for this weekend to see how it
goes they're actually going to have both
ups a night you can play dual ranked or
if you want to play in the tournament
it's entirely up to you so definitely
get feedback on the devs if you do enjoy
having both out out at the same time
some intended stuff also came into the
patch like some moves not training
stamina when the opponent is out of
stamina
like Raiders charge except this change
is being reverted because not all the
changes that came with they were
implemented at the same time so don't
get your hopes up it
be back in probably a week or so but
there will be other changes coming with
it and she Gopi also got nerfed because
of a bug fix now she go [ __ ] not demons
embrace somebody when they activate
revenge this change is also being
reverted just like the previous one I
mentioned both these changes will be
gone from the game on Tuesday but like I
said they will be back in the future
once everything has been implemented
together on top of that there's going to
be a road map coming for August and the
most important thing on the road map is
that the new event that was teased is
coming as well and those are the tiles
in the middle which look a bunch of
volcanoes stuff coming around in the
background not sure what this entirely
is but more on that coming next week
according to the devs on these really
cool possible event coming to foreigner
so let me know what you guys think is
going to be in this new event I hope
it's really damn cool personally I'm
always a big fan of the Mount Agnes or
volcano since I'm Midnight's player so
let me know what you guys think at the
comments below about this event the
content of the week is three battle
outfits they are available for all
heroes and they're going to be
discounted permanently so if you do want
to grab those you can the outfits are
going to be triumphant splendor
dauntless brigade and gamblers fallacy
personally I do like the dauntless
brigade outfit it ain't bad considering
has a nice little cool camo touch to it
so if you want like I said if you want
to buy those you definitely can and with
that guys it's going to be the end of
the base today hopefully guys did enjoy
it like I said tune in next week and
we'll be getting lots of info on the new
event so if we got sticker on for this
video and for that video and then I
believe the week after that we're going
to be eating some gameplay of the new
PvE game-mode that's supposed to be
coming a marching fire which they're
either going to show what games come or
on the dev stream so every Thursday just
like I said tons of info coming in the
next couple weeks for some future for
honor stuff so as always stay tuned to
the channel for that see I like the view
can do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
covered the informational site a
foreigner that being bells changes hero
updates patch notes leaks all that good
stuff and with that guys my two most
recent videos would be on screen if you
guys to want to check that out when that
guys have ever greatest err day think of
Arts in the video a peace out
[Music]